hi and welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens on Tuesday Netflix
released the official teaser trailer for
The Witcher season 3 which will be split
into two parts five episodes releasing
on June 29th and the final three
episodes releasing on July 27th this
will be Henry cavill's final run as girl
as Liam Hemsworth will be taking over
the role for season four and like this
teaser Everything Changes sad to watch
cavali but excited to see what Hemsworth
can do but for now let's stick to what's
happening in season three what we should
be prepared for and break this trailer
down scene by Saint xiaowie before we
get into this I want to summarize where
we left off in season two so be warned
I'll be spoiling season two like right
now from Julia the noof guardian
sorceress Francesca the leader of the
elves after philov Andro failed and
Jennifer have found themselves at the
hands of the deathless mother who we
later find out is one of the members of
the wild Hunt a demon who feeds off pain
later referred to as ball of Mir with
the witchers in prison a long time ago
and all she wants is Siri on the other
side of the Season we find out series
the key to all of these monoliths that
are allowing creatures from the other
worlds to enter she also has Elder blood
which can also be used to make more
witchers and she may bring upon the end
of days with the wild Hunt Jennifer
teaches Siri to open a portal and they
escape to a nearby monolith but Jennifer
changes her mind a little too late and
balthamir has already escaped entering
series body they have a pretty unfair
fight at CareMore and Jennifer offers
herself as a host slitting her wrist
freeing Siri from voldemir but then Siri
transport the three of them to an
unknown World involves mayor leaves
Jennifer's Body and we get a glimpse of
the wild Hunt who plans to take Siri but
Siri transports them back to care more
and now garal plans to protect his new
family basically everyone on the
continent is after Siri now this is a
mirrors after Siri the Brotherhood and
the northern monarchs put a hit out on
Siri after Francesca killed a bunch of
human babies thinking they killed her
baby she finds out Siri has Elder blood
that can rebuild the elf Society the
emperor Amir who actually killed
Francesca's babies after Siri and is
revealed to be serious father Dooney
never died a lot is literally going on
right now no
I understand real fear
for the looks of it he's in a cave but a
cave that opens to the coast possibly a
beach this could be thanated island we
see a girl pulling out his steel sword
and as a reminder like in the games he
does have two swords the other is
usually on his horse the steel sword has
renfrey's brooch on the hill and is
meant to kill a man and monster his
silver sword is softer and better for
fighting different kinds of monsters
magical or Supernatural ones the steel
sword translates an elder speech to my
gleam penetrates the darkness my
brightness disperses the Gloom also by
the looks of this scene he is probably
up against man but if the scene is
directly connected to the beginning of
the trailer when he takes the Elixir
then he could be going up against one
very powerful man or a couple of people
but by this blurry scene it looks like
it's just one person the voiceover is
girl saying now for the first time I
understand real fear which I assume is
directly related to protecting Siri
Netflix released a description for
season 3 saying as Monarch's Mages and
beasts of the continent compete to
capture her geralt takes Siri into
hiding determined to protect his newly
reunited family against those who
threaten to destroy it they must fight
back put everything on the line or risk
losing each other forever it's like the
saying in the last of this goes I was
never afraid before you showed up now
the girl has a family worth protecting
and potentially losing he sees the
danger he's really in we see our first
look at Siri in the trailer this could
be a dream sequence seeing how slow and
choppy the shot is nonetheless she's
stressed in fear riding horse back to
get away from the wild Hunt emerging
from the clouds of smoke in the forest
the last time we saw the wild Hunt was
in the last episode of season two and
like I said earlier both Mir is a member
of the wild Hunt but in blood Origins
Captain iridine played by Jacob Collins
Levy is banished to the barren unknown
red world and finds the bone-shaped
helmet in the sand which is the helmet
to the leader of the wild Hunt we're
getting small glimpses at their
backstory throughout the series already
and it's perfect now as a reminder some
people in The Witcher think the wild
Hunt is a myth but after the second
season we clearly see their super real
and voldemir did so much damage as just
one member so the full package seven
will be horrendous if they escape their
world in the show and in the fourth book
the wild Hunt wants Siri to join them in
this season we'll probably get more
information about Series history in
regards to her family's bloodline
because she's clearly Precious Cargo to
everyone involved we are all so excited
for The Witcher to come back and if you
want more Slavic fantasy goodness in the
form of a new upcoming single go play
our game then listen up Gord is a dark
fantasy strategy game set in a hostile
land inspired by Slavic Mythology
besieged by vile creatures you must
build to survive but to Prevail you must
conquer the darkness beyond the gates
take command of the tribe of the Dawn
and embrace the ethical complexity of
leadership as you Shepherd the community
their safety Insanity are your
responsibility protect them from Hunger
disease and Trauma nurture their faith
and train them for battle in return they
will pledge their loyalty and lay down
their lives in a land that lusts for
blood every family will learn sacrifice
it sounds awesome I'm such a lore junkie
and Gore does double duty for my lore
fix and my exploration fix the chronicle
explains the history of the gourd
universe that blends real world Slavic
mythology and Dark Fantasy Paige is torn
from The Chronicle are scattered
throughout the game and by collecting
those pages you get insight into the
origins of gods ancient factions and
mystical Whispers give it to me give me
Gordon is coming summer 2023 to steam
Xbox series Xs and Playstation 5. stay
up to date and don't miss a Beat by
signing up through the link in the
description box below we get our first
look at Jennifer in the trailer then it
catch to eritus of the school of
sorceress where Jennifer was taken to in
season one and where we know this woman
from get up the then we jump to a door
opening Flames almost engulfing the
unfazed reents last we saw rants in
season two he got bested by garal and
Escape but reported back to Lydia he had
messed up and gave her the Witcher
making potion when she performed the
blood tracing ritual The Witcher potion
messed her face up like bad they
continued their plan to capture Siri a
new actors playing reince Chris Fulton
wasn't available to film season three so
it's Sam wolf now andrian's arms is a
beautiful cat oh dare I say the most
beautiful cat in the world now we
briefly see this cat Esmeralda in season
2 episode 6. it belongs to code ringer
and Finn and if you've read times of
contempt you're aware of what happens
but I don't want to spoil anything but
keep in mind istrid went to visit them
to find some very sensitive information
so they'll be clearly making a big
return this season then we come to fill
up with the ask here we saw Philippa in
the finale of season two she works with
Dykstra and Kim transformed from an owl
the extra commanded that she bring the
bar demanding its time he paid back his
benefactor in the books this
relationship between him and yaskir was
explored but not really in the series so
this is opening some new doors for us in
the quickest cut we see Siri lift the
sword but to whom which again I don't
want to spoil who she's fighting but
there's been released photos of the
fight scene online that's not hard to
find if you want to be spoiled you can
search for it on your own I'm not giving
it away because I don't like giving
spoilers away the next cut is garal and
Ran's going at it this looks like the
same place from the beginning of the
trailer behind garage it looks like
they're in the little Cavern there are
high chances that girl took the Elixir
to fight Rands and he's using the silver
sword what has Ryans gotten into will he
finally be one of many to capture Siri
is his employer someone incredibly
deadly we see rants a lot in this
trailer so our boys making a complete
comeback we're back with Jennifer she's
in a different attire all together in
the background we see Villa vandro and
Francesca as Jennifer is doing some
Magic series directly behind her
watching the fight the soldiers are
literally going at it clearly people are
here to take Siri they're currently at
the ruins of sherawit the first episode
of season three will take place here
because it's the title of the first
script so this could pick up after the
finale of season two showrunner Lauren
has Rick spoke in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly discussing how this
episode will be the Newfound family
start at mending the relationship after
volathmir destroyed it but also this
location is a great setting to learn
more on the Elven history in which blood
origin will come into play we'll be
exploring Jennifer and growth's
different versions of it all when
telling Siri hesrick said we're gonna
start to understand everybody has a
different version of historical events
which can get messy Sherwood is a very
important location in the book it's an
ancient Elven place that was destroyed
200 years before the books and the show
it was introduced in Blood of Elves and
it's where geralt and Siri have a
conversation about girl wanting to be
neutral and the importance of that he
says to be neutral does not mean to be
indifferent or insensitive you don't
have to kill your feelings it's enough
to kill hatred within yourself after
both mirror took her over and killed a
bunch of witchers in series body I can
see Siri probably feeling like a
nuisance and the problem so maybe your
point of view will start teetering on
self-hatred and grow out like the Father
Figure he now is we'll fix that then we
jump to the scene of Siri lost in what
seems to be amazed calling out to girl
Jennifer and girl are also in the same
Maze and everyone's dressed so well it's
like they've come to a party Jennifer I
think is wearing the same outfit she
wore in season one when she first met
girl at the orgy that she started people
on the internet think this is the
bellatin festival which is the spring
love and fertility Festival that in
Sword of Destiny brought me Jennifer in
there's mentioned in different
interviews of yaskir possibly finding a
love interest in series sexuality being
explored so there could be more people
at the festival celebrating that we just
haven't seen yet once girl pulls out his
steel sword you know they're in that
maze with someone else possibly Rand
he's everywhere that's when we see what
could be Siri facing a large blurred out
creature some think it could be a
shellmar from The Witcher games there
are some things we didn't get into
because it wasn't in this trailer that
we know are being explored in season 3
like yaskir possibly finding a love
interest Siri sexuality being explored
additionally after blood origin we also
know avalock escaped with Central's book
and is the person revealed to be
standing in the doorway in season one so
in hopes that we can expect some time
travel we haven't really got a glimpse
of this call back in the trailer yet the
fact of the series dad is the White
Flame and not dead at Sea this is just a
teaser trailer so I'm sure we'll see
more on later trailers or maybe even
release press a lot happen at the end of
season 2 in blood origin so it's hard to
throw 10 different story lines into this
trailer but I'm sure they'll reveal most
of the answers closer to June's release
that's it for my breakdown on the newest
trailer for the season 3 of The Witcher
personally I'm more excited to see the
wild Hunt what are you most excited for
let me know the comments follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
peace
[Music]